i'm not sure you need to read any
further with that one yeah i don't
like it
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by lord
she's a two-time grammy award-winning
singer-songwriter and she's back with
her long-awaited much anticipated third
studio album solar power
the latest singles stoned at the nail
salon and solar power are available now
as well as a multi-continent tour set to
begin next year
lord welcome to the show thank you for
having me what's going through your head
right now as you prepare to chow down
this afternoon
well i am hungry the wings look pretty
good
um but i just said to you before i feel
like i'm inside the internet like it is
a weird
sensation to be here so i'm it's a
little surreal but i'm
i'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
oh the handle okay good to know
great
[Music]
delicious whack
this is yummy says at touchdown you have
an album on the way and then feeding the
fans in the meantime with your singles
stone at the nail salon and solar power
and i've heard you talk about threads
that run through your albums like the
house party motif and melodrama
is there a theme or even a color that
you can identify in this your most
recent era of music
totally yeah well the um color of
melodrama was
this kind of violet this egyptian violet
and this one was very much
gold kind of sun sun golden
hour type color i basically thought of
the album as
like a sun worship album i'm not
religious in any way but
my experiences and nature in the last
couple years were as close to
what i had experienced as religion so
it yeah it was like a sort of devotional
record
for me so i thought about it and just
very cold and
joyful
[Music]
mmm fresh flavor fruity so far hit and
right
hmm how could i like it
it's trying to wing my god it's been too
long
i'm just in the pop star life i feel
like you're not like smashing wings that
often you know
you got to look for an excuse like this
yeah yeah yeah
what do you think about the
geniusification of music like for music
fans what do you see as the pros and
cons of an artist decoding their own
lyrics
wow i actually when like a big release
comes out one of the first things i will
do is go on genius because i'm such a
lyric
nut in the past i'd always sort of
thought
it's all open domain like i sort of
wasn't precious about any details but as
i get older
i find myself saying no actually i'm not
going to explain that song
not because i necessarily need it left
up to interpretation but because it's
about something
that's very precious to me and
that i feel weird about like
commodifying via
you know something like genius but
there's also that sometimes the thing
where the fans will annotate it and
they're like
it has this many it's syncopated in this
way which represents this number and i'm
like oh no no no
it's too much it's not that deep all the
time you know
but i like it
[Music]
some little bits in it what are we
talking here yeah and see how it's kind
of clear but then shake up the box
so how often are you changing out these
sauces so every season you know
typically we'll do like a 12 episode
season and then uh put in our new
symphony of hot sauces every time
i love it well to the third leg and this
is kind of interesting
hmm
[Music]
yum smoky
big pepper bomb though really different
to the last one
really good and a little bit spicier
even
a little spicier but nothing lord can't
handle
we're only on wing three you know
i'm like do i keep double biting or do i
save the scovilles
do they layer on like how does it work
with the oh
there's definitely a cumulative effect
as you work your way through
that's what i thought so to my knowledge
you're the first person from new zealand
that we've ever had in the hot seat
still feel
humor so if you'll humor us we're hoping
to get a guide to the kiwi lifestyle
directly from the source
hokey pokey ice cream overrated or
underrated
i like it but i'm more preferential to a
cookies and cream which i know you have
here but i think of was like a very
new zealand ice cream i read that in new
zealand sheep outnumber people something
like ten to one
for those of us who aren't lucky enough
to live in a part of the world where
that type of thing is happening
how do you explain the allure of
devotion cheese
[Music]
i don't know like i'm a bit of a cheese
connoisseur i love cheese and kind of
the
zanier the better like i've never met a
cheese that was too
funky and crazy for me so devotion is
actually pretty chill it's a sheep's
milk cheese
it just has this yeah just the slight
grassiness that i really like
i would bring you a lump but i think
that's illegal oh really to like yeah
bring it into the
yeah the pasteurization i don't know so
i gotta catch a flight
i don't fly you know yeah come down and
i'll i'll do your cheese board
hell yeah i'll take you up on that all
right lordy ready to move on here to the
floor i'm ready i'm ready
hot ones barbacoa here sick
[Music]
this is a really delicious lunch i'm not
gonna lie so far
so far at number four yeah
[Music]
so i know that you love the growling
tiger that's at the top of the bridge of
your song sober
can you give us another example of being
drawn to an effect in the
jack antonoff library of strange sounds
so this album features a lot of cicada
yeah singing cicada music and solar
power in solar power yeah
and uh that was something that i just
started
um recording on my phone in new zealand
because
the sound of cicadas to me it's so
emblematic of new zealand summer and i
loved the idea of
immortalizing that on this record so i
did i just would go outside every time i
would hear them
raging and and get a little recording
but uh
i didn't realize that this year's
brood x which is this big kind of
boom of cicadas once every 17 years the
last time it happened was in
2004 when um
i guess jlo and ben affleck were
together and now
so people are like oh like brutix like
it's in there so i guess i'm uh
i'm right on trend with my cicada moment
but
i have been taking the recordings for a
couple of years
[Music]
i'm intrigued by this yellow guy ginger
goat pineapple and ginger yummy
all right lord we have a recreation
segment on our show called explain that
graham we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context
challenge us a little bit with yours
we'll show you the pictures over here on
the monitor you just tell us the bigger
story
this is during your glastonbury and your
coachella performances
you ended up using this big glass box
for dancers and i'm curious
how seriously do you think about stage
design
i don't know like making music is
amazing but you can do that on a very
small scale
in your bedroom but designing a tour
like that's
real [ __ ] you know that costs real money
i'm always like i always feel like it's
such a privilege to be like let's make
this thing out of steel and glass and
then
it shows up you know so super important
to me um
whoa i just like touched it yeah it was
closed closed i saw the eyebrows i was
gripping yeah
um i am a little itchy i'm gonna use
like a pinky okay um
so i'm pretty excited when i go to a
show and it's something more
real you know or more kinetic so the box
was a really cool
thing to get to make and you look down
on the crowd like i remember
it's very surreal and then when you have
all those different
moving parts you know and a multimedia
presentation
is there a time where the technology has
failed you during a live show
oh yeah um yes actually oh my god
we played this um festival called
bonnaroo
and it was like roasting hot and our
gear just started
frying and he was just standing on the
side of the stage waiting to go on
there was a comedian called um hannibal
buress he's done the show
yeah so he was there and i didn't know
who he was at the time but he was like
do you want me to go on and do a sit to
like keep them
and i was like no like who was this
person like
i was like i'm very stressed out i
probably should have taken him up on the
offer because that was nice of a
gentlemanly funny person so
thank you hannibal i feel like this is
me fighting against evil
you're not gonna lose to a wig
huh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yum she got myself so like a little
indian
cream yum
you really get that um cumin and
getting a real profile check it out well
coconut milk
ginger human garam masala
love it speaking to you i like it
soon artists like kendrick lamar frank
ocean somebody who actively avoids the
spotlight when you're in between
projects then you have that line in
solar power about throwing your cellular
device under the water
can you reach me no you can't how do you
think about creating that distance
between yourself and public attention
like is it just all about isolating
yourself so that you can create without
distractions or is it you
yearning for a sense of personal privacy
it's a combination of those two things
i am by nature a very private
introverted person so it sort of suits
me better but also i think
there's a certain kind of zone you can
get in when people are
gassing you up and telling you you're
the [ __ ] all the time you know i didn't
i felt you know obviously i sort of
became well known
super young 16 is a time when so much is
changing about yourself
and i feel like i made a real choice at
that age to
not really let that validation
change my day because you could be
you know maybe not showing up for your
loved ones and
it's just a slippery slope i think i
feel like i'm being boring i'm not like
no no no i'm not sizzling out like but
it's delicious i'm loving the wigs
well this next one
i'm about to eat my words might change
things so this is hotter than l
hotter than l
[Music]
i taste that scotch bonnet wow fruity
can you taste it though yeah but i like
that you have a you have a
a palette that can sense this i love
cocoa
that's nice is it unwise to double bite
at this point
let's just go yummy
hell yeah
dude you just like dab my nose
don't want to touch it okay
yeah so i know that you led your middle
school to a second place finish in the
2009
kids lit quiz world fight oh yeah yeah
i was like what's this going to be my
battle of the bands debut perhaps
the literature literature yeah one of my
finest achievements honestly
and then recently you changed your
instagram bio to be a quote by joan
didion
do you have a favorite literary
reference from one of your songs or
music videos
um that's a really good question
definitely for this last album something
a quote that i thought about a lot
by a writer called annie dillard was um
how we spend our days
as how is of course how we spend our
lives um
i've been thinking about the midsummer
night's dream recently actually
it was something i read as a kid that i
was so it was so evocative
the kind of depictions of being outside
in the sunshine you know these like
kind of fairies and and centaurs and
stuff sort of
frolicking so i i went back and read
some of that and it you know obviously
still holds up
shakespeare still holds up don't know if
you know that about it but
uh some [ __ ]
[Music]
this one's pretty dark in a way that
looks a little concerning
sizing it up
[Music]
it's almost bitter
there's not a lot of redeeming qualities
you know i saw how you checked out the
teacup masala ingredients
i'm not sure you need to read any
further with that one yeah i don't
like it no one does
so that's been around for a while for
this reason
you know i feel it yeah the bitterness
is really the overwhelming quality
wow but your composure through this
thing it's
a sight to behold it's hot it's awesome
last month you published a photo book
called going south which crowd
called your trip to antarctica what's
the most memorable experience you had
with wildlife in the south pole it's
been kind of a theme throughout the
season we had david harbor on and he
went to visit the penguins oh that's
right
um you know about david harper going to
see the pen i actually do
he went to antarctica also because not
many people go there so i think i saw
him and i was like
tell me more um well i had this crazy
experience i went
out uh with a whale scientist
on this like midnight whale tracking
expedition
and we went this helicopter and they had
like
all the doors and windows open which
seemed insane to me but
[Music]
it is hot um and uh
yeah we just uh kind of flew along the
ice shelf because you can't fly over
open water in antarctica but it's so
dangerous
so uh this crazy surreal experience of
it being midnight
and we're like flying over this kind of
channel
looking for these orca still to this day
like i don't think i have done
anything cooler than that and maybe
never will like it's probably it
i'm doing good it's uh i do yeah i feel
it
you know you said when you walked in
you're like oh i feel like i'm in the in
the matrix you know
seeing the seeing the black curtain and
then yeah you're going to draw like
the zings onto me the noise
yeah i need to like do an expression
that you i'll be like
and i don't look crazy yeah wait till
you see what colin does with that one
oh wait
[Music]
i can imagine like people totally
panicking like
it's a high stress way to do it my nose
is just like pouring
okay all right so this next one
is the scorpion disco i love that spot
yeah funkin hot
[Music]
that's nice that's a nice little way
everything is a little bit easier it's
almost a two biter oh all right well if
if you called two better
[Music]
i like it
still mean favorite flavor wise was this
hella pepper take it take it with you
take it with you thank you yeah [ __ ]
thank you
whatever you want whatever you want lord
we're hooking it up yum
so a lot has been made about your
undercover instagram account where you
review
onion rings which was active at least as
recently as last april
as an aficionado of the art form what
two are the keys to a perfect onion ring
okay i want
an onion that has been cut thickly
i'm not you know i want like kind of
like this i want a pretty
toothsome vertical bite
i want a pretty crisp
yet thick crust you know i want it to
have some
substance i guess i'd probably more be
into a
battered than a crumbs um you're forced
to make a choice yeah and forced to make
a choice so that's maybe the way that my
my bias skews um i like a white onion
although i have had a few
red onion rings that have you know
caught my eye so but i feel like chicago
would be a good
uh it's a good idea city town i don't
know why i get that vibe it just seems
like
yeah midwest yeah yeah yeah onion ring
you know what that but that assumption
it's not it's not misguided it's true it
is it's an onion ring
it's an onion ring town and what i find
with an onion ring you know to me the
minus points on an
onion ring is when you bite in you need
the onion part
to break on the bite okay sometimes
you'll pull out nothing more than the
three
pull that thing right i don't want to
get down with that no that to me is what
makes an onion ring makes a mockery of
the institution i completely agree
yeah i want that separation to happen
same page right there
this is the last dab of the last dab
because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last wing you
don't have to if you don't want to
but i can see where this is headed
oh you can see what
[Music]
years and years of celebrities accosting
this sauce
right right there's you know what i mean
it's it's any press is good press in the
hot sauce game
so can i ask you do you have like a
crazy amount of hot sauces at home or
are you like
ugh so you just can't think about hot
sauce when i go home so that's that's a
good question so when it comes to wings
i'm over wings you know i don't want to
eat another wing if i'm
off the clock and then everybody thinks
of me as like
people see yeah do you get like a wing
sent over yes
all the time rings it's love i
appreciate it you know but like every
time i'll sit down it's like oh and this
is from the chef
present me wings and i'm like all right
thank you it's very sweet but then also
the other thing is like
i'll have friends that are like i'm
visiting seattle like where's the best
spot to get wings like i have this
encyclopedic knowledge of every wing
spot in the country like i'm an expert
on wings
wings i'm over i've turned the corner
but because of the show and perhaps
counter-intuitively
i have gained a new appreciation and
love for hot sauce because you meet all
these different makers and you hear all
these different stories
and then i've tried so many different
kinds and seen the way that it
elevates food and changes things on a
culinary level so to answer your
question i now
love hot sauce even more and i even have
uh
a whole uh just you open a cabinet in my
kitchen
that's just a hall of fame wall of hot
sauce that goes like
five shelves deep i love that i love
that view i just did a hearty
last time cheers
yum look at that bonnet just enjoying
just out here
having lunch lord
double bite oh no
the perils of wearing white on your wing
show
disaster okay lord really delicious
finally we've made it to the end here
and if we've learned anything all
along the way it's that you're a
stalwart of pop music
beautifully obsessed as evidenced by
this quote a lot of musicians think they
can do pop
and the ones who don't succeed are the
ones who don't have the reverence
who think it's just a dumb version of
other music you need to be awestruck
it's a simple question but feel free to
take it as deep
as your hot sauce soaked brain wants to
go what do you find sacred about pop
music
um i'll put the wing down for that
that's how seriously i
take that question well ever since i was
a kid even before i made anything
i had the sneaking suspicion that it was
more difficult to
speak to a lot of people than it was to
speak to a small amount
there's something really special about
that and just like i love you know
writing a pop melody
like there's nothing better you know for
it to be simple but just
secretly complex and to kind of trick
the brain
it's probably not disabled
[Laughter]
you know you can't you can't fake it
it's a it's a it's a real experience so
that's kind of what it is for me just
that feeling of being able to talk to a
lot of people
um and to make something that is kind of
high brow but also
you know can can be enjoyed in really
really simple ways
drop the wing and drop the mic lord
taking on the wings of
death and living to tell the tale toss
them
now i really enjoyed this thank you for
having me
i enjoyed speaking to you today this was
such a lovely experience and now lord
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life oh
this bit okay i have an album coming out
it's called solar power
it's out on august 20th so uh check it
out if you want to
but uh mainly check out hot ones
thank you thank you this was really fun
i had a great time what was your second
favorite
um i do like that ginger gut and i
really like that um
scorpion disco that was nice and you
liked the name but i love you
[ __ ] hop
[Laughter]
i love that you're like the high priest
of this
i know it's just like source universe
like could you ever have expected that
this would be your life
hey what's going on everybody shawn
evans here just wanted to say thank you
so much for watching today's episode
and it's happened the day has finally
come for the youtubes hot ones toy
that's right the u2's hot ones toy is
available
july 29th at 3 p.m eastern time
at shop.firstbeatfeast.com that's
shop.first we feast.com
to get your hands on the hot ones you
choose toy look at this
got the table got the sauces got the
milk
the wings on deck it's handsome if i do
say so myself